кандидат у президенти франції вид парку
республіканці франсуа фійон буквально за
кілька днів у бідність і все поспішаючи геть на
третьому місяці
перед вибір чиїх рейтингу
лисого ти за нього там ще думав
чисті важких тепер йдіть попит
чи правдиві курсом загрозою ти прозорі
сум не вираховуватиму зокрема
політики французький політик та моїх
багата влада і ведеться як наші
пращури як монархи виводити часом
французької революції ми знаємо shell та
монархи ось так і поклала край їх ним
проробиш сизо форсажі за змочувати все
ці скандали
політики претендують на високому уралі нас
правді він іншої їжі та бандити ми моєму
за тих tps за рейтингом фійон авторів
скандал догола його дружиною поні лапи-то
на будь їм тофікти в ній роботі
зарубала 830 тисяч євро продажів 15 уроки
у так якщо я приміряю театрі мене
хороші з бюджету дітьми фійону
кандидату президенти чекав 5 води не
світіння поліції питання ви більше ні в
французів
оладки ви ще на знімати і мастис виборі
однак у парку республіканці житуха
потягніть
коли я на партійному з'їзді можете брати
через хвилину ми не можемо ще раз
проводьте по передній вибір з
думаю я буду вдома в лоні зми шпильку ми
кандидатами та мису твердому нову
кандидатуру вони поки що в процесі
знайдіть
дві третини на французі поважають ще фійон
майє знято свою кандидатуру спаровування
tanks а сам пенелопа gate на руку
популісти марин ле пен зал станемо і досвід
його ним з першого туру, а нам уже випили
дірку you a big наші малюки фійону align
та за лижного кандидата
емануелем акрона у тимура училища
mashme крону та lap and 65 адже сотки
респондентів ви славилася азама крона і
вище 35 за праву популіст q